thank you very much I know we're in it
together right that's the important
thing we're in this together cuz even by
normal Trump weeks this was I made so
much crazy [ __ ] happen I'm just have to
go through it chronologically first up
you heard the hope pics was voted off
the island and you know hope pics this
was Trump's you know his work wife his
emotional companion animal whatever she
did there and this has really thrown him
off because she was one of the few
people he could work with they were a
very good team she was a former model
and everything he says makes you want to
throw up so it's very it's very ironic
because he was very dependent on hope
pics and his whole presidency is about
giving Hicks hope so
she is 29 years old 29 the
communications director for the
President of the United States of
America a communications director by the
way that known in America has ever heard
speak in fire and fury he says her main
job during the campaign was steaming
Trump's husky boy sack suit while it was
on him she would sit in a chair in front
of him and blow dry his crotch also on
her resume she used to date Corey
Lewandowski who was from campaign
manager and married at the time then she
dated Rob Porter who had to leave the
White House earlier in the month in a
wife-beating scandal you know I'm not
that familiar with soap operas but I
think in the next episode Trump gets
amnesia and Mike Pence reveals he's a
woman I think
[Applause]
anyway she's gone off to pursue other
opportunities yes she feels you could be
much more effective steaming the pants
and creepy old men in the private sector
[Applause]
so now the prettiest deaf-mute in the
West Wing is Jared oh yes in other news
from the Lancaster clan I mean the
Lannister clan [ __ ] I should have gotten
the HBO joke right good night
the knives are really out for Jared
Kushner he lost his top security
clearance there's an Archie Bunker
meathead thing going on with general
Kelly and oh it turns out that every
inexplicable fucked-up thing that's
happened in the last year is really
because Jared's trying to get 1.2
billion dollars to pay for a building
each shouldn'ta bought he really this is
all making sense though he had meetings
with two banks in the White House who
gave him five hundred million dollars
and his security clearance has over a
hundred omissions and errors on it I can
say this because my mother was Jewish
he's too stupid to be a Jew
[Applause]
hi I want to see his birth certificate I
do right I think it's gonna say
birthplace Alaska real name Jarrod Palin
he is an Orthodox Jew and they're
already setting up a prison for
unleavened worth but but I love this
sources say that Trump is siding with
general Kelly to try to get general
Kelly to help get Jared and Ivanka out
of the White House
finally a Trump issue that real
Americans can relate to not being able
to get your grown kids out of the house
[Music]
so okay hope IX's god rob Porter is gone
they say McMaster the national security
adviser one of the adults he's gonna
learn a few weeks left maybe Gary Cohen
the treasurer's who is going to be left
Trump's gonna be all alone in the White
House talking to a soccer ball with a
face painted on it and you know all this
chaos makes it very difficult for the
NRA to run the country
whoo and they do I think we saw that
this week oh did you see Trump at the
White House with that bipartisan meeting
when he freaked out Republicans when he
suggested raising the gun age from 18 to
21 and seizing the guns of people who
pose a threat he said this is the actual
words from Donald Trump president I like
taking the guns early take the guns
first go through due process second
that's right Republicans turns out there
is a president who'll ignore the
Constitution to come for your guns the
ones you [ __ ] idiots voted for
[Applause]
[Music]
all right k earmuffs kids put all the
most I must say galling things that I've
ever heard him say maybe the most
revolting you heard what he said this
week I really believe I'd have run in
there even if I didn't have a weapon of
course he was talking about the dressing
room with the Miss Teen USA pageant well
things are changing
you know how corporate America Dick's
Sporting Goods is no longer selling
ar-15 shows how much this debate has
shifted huh when a company says we're
not selling assault weapons and we're
dicks